he should have been oliver dowd and
talking to us today but of course he has
resigned this is an absolute disaster
for the party isn't it
it's not been a a a good evening by any
stretch of imagination so
you you heard from robert there speaking
a lot of senses ever we've got to
reflect we've got to
to listen really carefully and we have
to respond um and what we uh
knows that people are going to be um
concerned in the months and years to
come about the cost of living about
inflation pressures
and when robert talked about the next
election you don't win you don't just go
up to win an election you have to
actually govern well and then people
reward you for that and
your
hopes and aspirations for the next
period um after that and so we need to
prove to people that we do have those
answers how to grow the economy and how
to tackle um the cost of living issue
which the 37 billion pounds package that
the chancellor has brought in is the um
is the first of that but it's not
business as usual we will reflect we
will listen and we will respond
yeah someone must take responsibility is
what oliver dowden says should it be the
former chairman of the party is it his
responsibility
well i mean oliver
you know he's he's a good man he's
worked um really hard in that role i've
learned him for a long time and uh he
he's done what he thinks is the right
thing he's organized those by-elections
he and he i i know he takes it
personally
he's taken a personal decision there um
but in terms of taking responsibility
the prime minister's always said that uh
the responsibility for all of the things
that happened within his government uh
lie within him and that's why he is
going to reflect why he's going to
listen and he is going to respond it's
it's um it's now making sure that we can
act on behalf of the people under his
leadership
what does he have to do in order to not
be the right person for the job
i think
he's the head of the government that uh
at a really crucial time in our um
economic cycle and and our uh history
this is a guy that uh as i say he's
managed to um get some uh big
significant things done getting that
brexit um paralysis that we had i'm not
getting through hobid he's now facing
down uh the cost of living issue that
i've been talking about and so
you know it's his brazen approach that's
going to come up with those big ideas
and boost the confidence in our economy
yeah and yet still
elect by-election after by-election
after by-election after by-election the
british people don't have faith in
i think you saw um conservative
conservatives in the 1980s lost
something like 15 by-elections uh under
margaret thatcher and won
each of the general elections uh you do
that by actually you know understanding
that by-elections can be you know
chances for mid-term protests and it's
important that we listen to those
protests why exactly is it that people
are saying hold on a sec not business as
usual we want you to respond in
accordingly and
that's exactly what we're doing so we
want to make sure that we have uh not
just have the right answers for growing
the economy and tackling the possibility
but we've
got cost of living but we're
communicating that with them with people
in tibetan wakefield and other parts of
the country exactly what we are doing to
support them
losing two by elections on the bounce
with 20 odd thousand seat majorities
it's unheard of
well in terms of the the the numbers in
tibetan um you know that it was it was
particularly high but no it's it's it's
not unheard of to actually have
by-elections um that the um governments
are losing mid-term i talked about the
uh no twenty-one
mr scully yeah the big the the big
numbers and uh this is when you have a
party that you have in the demonstration
sync at the uh uh activity camp down
there you have the labor party of the
wakefield with that sort of um
semi-progressive alliance uh that's been
talked about so they could um divide
their efforts in in that way
um and people felt that they could
either stay at home uh and abstain from
on this or make it like a protest and
that's what we've got to respond to now
and that's what we will respond to now
oliver dyn was an early and ardent
supporter of boris johnson 2019 june of
2019 writing in the times newspaper the
tories are in deep peril only boris
johnson can save us now he no longer
thinks that
no all of us
resign i'm not going to uh you know read
into his uh letter what may or may not
be there you know he said it out in the
way that he wants to um i'm not going to
speculate on
any further on that i just thank oliver
for all of the incredible work he's done
and i need to speculate he's gone
no speculation though
no i just i took from your question that
you're reading into why what you know
further about why he was um he's gone um
you know as i say he's that he's done
great work and i know he'll be back
doing other other um leading roles in
the conservative party in the certain
league with the certain government but i
come back to the fact that we are now
having to reflect um and it's right that
we do so but then come back
uh with a really good positive response
for what people are facing now because
come the next general election people
will vote
for what's in their pocket and what they
see is their uh hopes and aspirations
for the next um few years in terms of
the economy uh in particular and that's
what you've got to work with my point
was that he said only boris johnson can
save us now he quite obviously now feels
that that is not the case and he no
longer wants to serve in his government
so if not him then whom
no there's no that's well that's not
what i took from it i mean oliver is the
chairman that organizes the um uh you
know the violations and he's taken up a
personal view but um you know he's he's
carried the can for that i think in
reality
that's not what he says
not what he says at all is it um
well
but about speculating what he said i
mean if you want to speak to other
speakers
they're in front of us
well he said no but i mean he hasn't
said anything about the prime minister
in the in the letter and he's just said
exactly
someone's taking responsibility i've
taken responsibility as chairman and and
he's gone and i i wish him very much all
the best so but that's exactly the point
he's not said anything about the prime
minister he's purposefully
said that he remains loyal to the
conservative party not the prime
minister normally you would expect back
people when they're going to the back
benches to say that they remain loyal to
the prime minister he also says somebody
must take responsibility and i have
concluded that in these circumstances it
would not be right for me to remain in
office he's not saying that he is taking
responsibility but nobody else is
okay i'll happily talk about what's in
the letter what can't do is talk about
what's not in the letter and because i'm
not i can't second guess
oliver speculate what you know people up
and down i know that we always have
these things straight after elections
but what people
will have done in tibetan and wakefield
they've sent a message clearly to this
government to the prime minister to all
of us in government um that they want uh
to see
uh a changing approach um and
make sure that we can respond to the the
pressures that they're facing i think
what you'll find that's why i talked
about the communication because we've
already started to change our approach
in both the number 10 uh and making sure
that we're way more facing
in uh front facing in terms of tackling
those customer living issues we don't
always get our message across as
effectively as we might um but we need
to do more to make sure that we cannot
just tackle the lowest paid uh concerns
about the in particular about the cost
of living but growing in the economy as
well because that's the best way of
getting us out of this global pressure
that we're facing at the moment the lord
barwell who you will know and many of
our viewers will as well he was
basically the right-hand man for theresa
may when she was prime minister he said
on this program this morning if you keep
boris johnson in power the conservatives
will absolutely lose the next election
now why would he be so wrong do you
think given that he has been at the very
seat of power and he knows what it's
like
because he had the same thing um when he
was there you know a lot of people were
saying similar things about theresa may
i was yeah
i remember
i come in for this die news but i was
out um defending her having supported
her um
her deals as well
but what i'm saying is that gavin's been
through those pressures um and uh
he he has his own views it doesn't mean
he's right i mean you know everybody's
got a different view
within the conservative party
what we now need to do is you know not
have a three-month psychodrama of
leadership campaigns we need to actually
um when we when we're facing
rail strikes and pressures from other
unions as well we want to make sure that
we can tackle those so that we don't go
into a spiraling regulation that we saw
i'm old enough to you know remember when
that happened in the 70s and 80s
and there's a whole generation that
don't realize what can happen to an
economy quite quickly if you don't get
those things right now in the here and
now over the next three months not not
in six months or nine months or a year's
time
sources are telling us uh this morning
on the programme that
boris johnson was surprised by the
resignation of his chairman how
surprised were you
um
i i was reasonably surprised um but but
there again you know i say i'm in south
london by the shore since every wonder
so i haven't been part of those
conversations enough i suppose um uh
prime minister you know wouldn't have
been directly involved so um it's always
a shame when someone um like oliver goes
because as i say he's a good man um
he's worked and done great things for
for this government and for the party
you know and so they will do more things
in the future for with us and for us um
but it's a shame to see him go
um just looking um via the reuters news
agency
uh conservative party source by-election
defeats were partly the result of
endless media reporting about parties in
downing street do you support that
suggestion that it's the media's fault
that the prime minister has found
himself in this position
i think there was a cycle of of um of
that that people have been um chasing
the prime minister
since he was mayor and and before he's
always been probably one of the most
highly scrutinized politicians in the
world and people have been gunning up
for him for some time
um and so the frustration and the anger
as i've talked to you
about on a number of occasions around uh
what happened number 10 joined during
coving uh
what was
somewhat was sort of like fed also
by some tribalism of people that wanted
to um to
attack the you know the the the prime
minister and this government because
it's their job to do so the labour party
etc um we've always just tried to focus
on
uh what we can do by changing the ethos
at number 10 to make sure the background
happened again to make sure that we can
face into
uh the issues of the day like requested
building
people have been gunning for the prime
minister for some time why would they do
that
well because there's um i mean that's
just a sheer probability of
statistical numbers you've got the labor
and the dems that want to get rid of the
prime minister because they want to form
a government without necessarily having
any ideas so their job specifically is
to get rid of the prime minister you get
parts of the media who's um who
their
singular aim is to get rid of the prime
minister but and that tends to feed a
narrative so i'm not talking about the
fact it is the media
as a whole does it but people do tend to
talk about um
you know what what gets what gets pushed
by
by those people on occasion because
people like to talk about the
westminster village and what's happening
in westminster rather than the issues
that people are facing all the way
through the interpreting around the
country well let's let's let's talk
about that then briefly should we before
we let you go mr scully we appreciate
you taking the time you know we've been
in um wakefield we've been in tibetan
we've been in several other
by-elections over the last few months um
and it would appear that all of those
people not in the westminster village or
in that little bubble that you've been
talking about don't want the prime
minister to be there anymore in fact
there's just in fact quite a lot of your
backbenchers don't want him to be there
anymore there's just a few of you who
sit around that cabinet table who want
the prime minister to remain in office
are you tone deaf
well i think your father is the majority
actually you said
could you said there's a few mps there's
a majority of mps that have confidence
in boris johnson that was paid by the
government by the prime minister by the
government because they have government
roles the 75 percent of the backbenchers
wanted him gone
okay if i didn't want the prime minister
to be in charge i would resign as a
minister and and and uh because i
wouldn't then be able to serve his
government clearly and maybe i'm not
going to do this just because of you
know of a paycheck or something like
that this is way bigger than me or any
individual this is about the government
of this country and having the right
prime minister and i still believe that
the current prime minister boris johnson
is the man for that job he's been brazen
in his approach to get brexit done i
understand that mr scully i
my point to you is this my point to you
is this
yes i hear what you're saying and i hear
that that's what you're saying however
the majority of other people who are not
uh on the government payroll don't want
him in office anymore
so if you're talking about the uh you
know the population in westfield and uh
in wakefield and timberton uh then um
a lot as you again as you heard from
robert buckland a lot of postal votes
were going out during that vote with no
confidence there was a lot of um uh
talking in the media and elsewhere that
they would have been getting that news
of that particular event you know we we
are where we are now we've got to
reflect it's not business as usual we've
got to make sure that we can respond to
what we've heard on a what was not a
good night for the conservative party uh
and make sure that we
that we respond positively to let people
see that we do have the answers we
remain with those answers of how to grow
the economy and how to support people
through these difficult times
it's great to talk to you hopefully
we'll see you in person very soon thank
you very much indeed mr scrolling thank
you